the Joe Rogan experience I've been a fan
of yours forever man I was a huge Star
Wars fan when I was a kid and you
inspired me when I was young I really
wanted to be a makeup artist I wanted to
do special effects and the kind of stuff
that you do I had no idea yeah man I
think it was probably Star Wars that
kicked it off for me because I liked
many kids a lot of people today you know
we're so removed with first VHS and then
DVDs and laser discs and now streaming
it's so easy to watch movies but when
Star Wars came out we would go see it
over and over and over again it was like
a little contest between a lot of kids
that I went to school with I think I saw
it 13 times while it was out in the
movie theater but I became fascinated
I've always been fascinated with comic
books I always wanted to be a comic book
illustrator and I always loved like like
those fantasy novels like creepy and
eerie you know those those graphic
novels but I really became fascinated
with special effects and particularly
makeup after your work well you know
it's kind of the same thing for me I
mean I you know I I grew up in I was
born in 1950 you know I grew up in front
of a TV but it was a little black and
white one you know and and there was
always the monster movies on Saturdays
you know and or Sundays and that just
stuff just hit a chord with me and I
just said I have to do this you know
when did you what was the first thing
that you did first
first ever makeup yeah I did well I mean
that you know I was I'm an only child
yeah my mom wasn't supposed to have kids
because she had a bad heart and stuff
and but they wanted children and but I
was very shy I stayed in my bedroom I
couldn't talk to an adult and stuff like
that yeah the very first thing you know
I got interested in makeup and I got
some just white greasepaint and black
greasepaint and smeared it on my face
and just with a layer of grease paint on
my face when I was looking in the mirror
wasn't a little Ricky Baker anymore and
I could do things that I couldn't do
without this [ __ ] smeared on my face
yeah and it just it helped me overcome
my shyness but I mean it it started with
that but I mean I but uh I wanted to do
something more you know so I ended up
making I made my first mask
think when I was 13 and it was a curse
of Frankenstein Frankenstein and I did
that one mainly because I thought I
could copy that one make it look close
enough because it's it's there's some
crudeness to that makeup I've actually
it first didn't like it but I like it
now
you know I mean it's when you find out
how the film industry works in Port
Phillip Leakey who did that makeup had
like a week to prep you know and no
money so I did I forgive some of the
faults with it well it's great will you
stop and think about the earliest
versions of makeup in movies like
special-effects style makeup and movies
you know you go back to like Nosferatu
is probably one of the very earliest
right I mean they really didn't have
anything to go with there wasn't
anything to copy they kind of had to
make it up yeah and I mean you know the
thing is the Nosferatu is such I mean
it's great films great still to this day
yeah and and the look you know I mean it
shouldn't work by alright you know it's
like a big hook nose you know and I
don't know but it works great and but
yeah it's same thing I mean lon chaney
had nothing to work with raw spirit gum
and grime and he did to this day someone
still the bit my favorite makeups and
some of the best makeups and I think the
limitations in a lot of ways made the
makeup work better you know I mean now
we can add so much stuff and I find that
happen so much now like with that face
off show and stuff people it's more like
about how much can you pile on someone's
face you know but sometimes the most
effective makeups are Justin genius a
little bit of things that you do and a
lot of the humanity show through like
launch any and in Phantom of the Opera a
great makeup yeah that's a terrific and
Cheney was just brilliant and yes I'm
great at making scary faces that's how I
learned to make scary faces watching
Cheney movies
yeah he's another one there was like
there was not much to for him to go on
there wasn't he was kind of like a
pioneer yeah sure and I mean again like
I said it's still some of my favorite
makeups that and you know Jack Pierce's
Frankenstein's monster yes again
crude materials you know he you know it
was in you know poor Boris Karloff
what he had to endure I mean that isn't
is none of the makeups he did on Boris
were comfortable you didn't know it
cotton and spirit gum and collodion
collodion if you know you might know is
because of your fight background kind of
stuff but it's a plastic they used to
use it to close up
boxers wounds and stuff um it's like
kind of this liquid plastic but it
smells horrible and you know to be
working around someone's eyes with his
fumes of stuff and yeah I mean he had to
put up with a lot so it's kind of like a
glue yeah it says kind of a liquidy
plasticky stuff he pull up a video of
Nosferatu what year was that 20 I don't
know 1922 20 that's crazy yeah you stop
and think about that you know film
itself had only been how old then yeah
not very easy can get a video of it yeah
his just the whole thing about the way
he moved like everything it was so
creepy and interesting well in the whole
film him he's just beautifully shot I
mean so many of the silent films I mean
the photography is so incredible you
know I mean I wonder how what they did
with the fingers like how did they get
his fingers
well those I think those are just his
hands at this point you know I mean
later I mean in in like the John
Barrymore dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde mm-hm
you know they I remember reading and
Famous Monsters which was again my like
my Bible you know did you get Famous
Monsters at all yes yeah you said
creature you know sure you know they
said you know John Barrymore did the
whole transformation without makeup you
know and it's not true he's got finger
extensions on right I could pointed back
of a head you know yeah but yeah it's
nuts right - brilliant
so what did they do for his ears do you
know well I'm not sure what they were
made out of same with the bald head I
mean I know rubber existed then I mean
you can kind of see I mean he's got I
think it's probably just like a slip
rubber which is like a you know he'll at
what we Halloween masks are made out of
here's an bald head and nose yeah some
sort of prosthetic nose right yeah in
those big pointy teeth but again I mean
if you if you really kind of analyze it
and look at it you you think this is
stupid it'll never work you know and but
it works great and I also think it's
because Max Schreck was great
yeah there's some really cool things
with his hands and stuff well if you
didn't if nothing like this existed and
it was dark out and you saw a guy like
that in your house you would freak out
well you know that's a pretty terrifying
way it's not somebody in my house anyway
yeah someone's smiling with you
[Applause]